welcome back to the rock stars I'm Erik
Voss and Rick and Morty season 4 episode
5 finally addressed some subject matter
that they promised they never would
address weightlessness also time travel
but the time travel works so well this
episode largely because it was preceded
by impressively animated visual
storytelling with no dialogue just an
insane attention to detail so let us
break down all the subtle jokes and
animation details that you might have
overlooked here starting with episodes
title rattle star Rick lactic ax a nod
of course to Battlestar Galactica a
sci-fi series likely chosen for the
rattle pun and as kind of a thorough way
to hide the be time-travel twist similar
to the Rick lantus mix-up title as a
misdirect from the return of evil Morty
as the episode opens Rick uses two of
its opening lines to disk both Santa
Claus and Jesus Christ as Christmas
approaches don't train your child elide
Jerry even though you know tis the
season which makes you neutrally buoyant
which I find personally more impressive
conceptually
than walking on water but what do I know
I wasn't born into the God business I've
earned it after getting a flat tire in
space Rick reveals some new features of
his ship thought it was cooler than the
celebrity voice package but here flat
tire you should be walking this
Christopher Walken joke sets up an
amazing call back later this episode why
wouldn't I be Jerry Apophis with a
device Christopher Walken gave me after
a record session this joke works
brilliantly on three levels versus a
callback second as a nod to the fact
that Walken takes these weird pauses
whenever he talks and third a nod to the
movie clique in which Chris Walken gives
Adam Sandler of remotes that can control
his life like a recording
Rick repeatedly warns and scolds Morty
about staying in the ship this episode
he's referencing the ton of movies 2001
a Space Odyssey and gravity with the
female astronaut in that movie
connecting to the female snake astronaut
that bites Morty rick compares space to
SNL
think space is like Saturday Night Live
you see it every day so you dream of
being in it but it dreams of removing
all the air from your body and making
you float around it for eternity as a
flash mummified corpse this is the
writers referring to how for many
comedians SNL seems like a dream gig but
for many who have worked on that show it
crushes their souls and eternally labels
them as failures as Morty's starts to
slowly fade away from the snake
boys and he whales I don't think this is
a reference to anything in particular
there is a band Black Mountain there's a
Led Zeppelin track but I just think this
is another example of love crafty and
cosmic horror and how Morty is destined
for hell something that we have gotten a
glimpse of before Rick acquires the
anti-venom from the snake planet on his
screen we start to see all the snake
planet details that the animators snuck
into this episode there are snakes with
guns and berets refugee snakes a snake
prison and a snake military parade with
ICBMs in a wavy serpentine shape and of
course snake jazz while Jerry tries to
use his bounce to beat some guys
basketball but accidentally makes them
think he's racist because I have a
certain power I wanted to celebrate
before it goes away you know we got a
Nazi up here I love other guys eyebrows
go up the moment Jerry says certain
power Yanks Morty mourns the snake he
killed with two r2d2 candles and then
heads to the pet store to find a
replacement snake this story is filled
with little Easter eggs Morty's old dog
snuffles from season one is on dog food
packaging there's a meaningless sign our
prices are cold-blooded what if that
means and then a rectal axe laxative for
reptiles I presume as Morty steals
Rick's Keys there's the interdimensional
cable on the TV playing audio from a
plumpest commercial and then Morty
tosses lippy down to the snake planet in
which the animators went crazy to make
everything snake-like snake radar tech
reads the snake playboy with an
extra-long centerfold and other snakes
play baseball and the flagpoles in the
background are serpentine as are all of
the poles and columns and architecture
of every building on this planet as well
as many of the roads we see in overhead
shots a snake newspaper shows the snake
written language in which it's all just
based on s the ship that rescues slippy
is the SS and all the ships at fangs as
do all the military vehicles and the
news logo there's a snake president in a
snake White House briefing room his
collar is popped like the neck of a
Cobra his presidential seal has snakes
on it in the background there's a mural
of the snake George Washington Crossing
the Delaware and in the doctor's office
we see snake x-rays which is just like a
lion it's a it's a linear shape and the
state government recruits ailing
with sticks professor which is similar
to the plot of movies like arrival in
which amy adams uses her language
expertise to help the government connect
with aliens
slippy as a female astronaut returning
to earth different is also similar to
the plots of stories like lucy in the
sky extent and gravity and contact and
when the snake professor arrives you can
see how the washington monument is also
serpentine in a random little detail i
liked he uses his briefcase to cover his
head in the rain so slippies containment
rooms floor is covered in wood chips
like a pet snake cage and the professor
successfully translates the earth snake
hiss and slippy has sex with them is
actually what it looks like when snakes
bang I know it's terrifying and so by
breaking the language barrier between
the snakes this is how the formerly
racist snakes are able to advance
technologically meanwhile Rick Morty and
summer played down beat the nonsensical
board game that they played in the
season 3 episode Rick Nancy in the zone
and when Rick takes Beth to look for
Jerry we see how Rick keeps DNA of other
characters to partially clone them and
two barely alive but vocal monstrous
alternatives for when they go missing
besides Jerry Rick also has math teacher
mr. goldenfold pizza guy summer and cop
7 Jerry weighs himself down with a rock
and heads into a biker bar named Devil's
teat a sign reads all biker dance
adorable
Jerry fears the multiple fans on the
ceiling inside similar to the fizzy
lifting drink scene and willy wonka the
Chocolate Factory and speaking of fizzy
drinks I love that Jerry orders a Diet
Sprite remix strength that was
introduced and phased out in the early
2000s summer dances to snake jazz at a
slumber party with returning characters
Trisha whom Somers ex even left her for
in the were literally a conspiracy
episode Android nerdy band friend Nancy
from season one can you alter the course
of a species evolution like that without
repercussions gee I don't know Nancy can
you alter the course of being a giant
weird
sorry also later we need to discuss your
clothing and your weight that's fair
Morty appears to be mid tug as the first
snake assassin appears in the future via
an orb with a leather jacket snake
killing him with a shotgun
both nods to the Terminator series along
with the t800 style snake protector from
the future resistance made with an
appearance to try to appeal to humans
the snake robots while Morty the ape
child a callback to the season premiere
in which wasp
Rick shows how other species eyes humans
being descended from apes is equally
weird to them and during this brawl in
the garage you can see how the time
travel stuff box is tipped over with its
contents spilled out everywhere
reflecting how this
so it's finally playing with time travel
and breaking the no time travel rule
there's a Sarah Connor style monologue
explaining the post-apocalyptic snake
future let's make robots crushing snake
skulls like a t2 Judgment Day
there are snake hovercrafts and snake
rovers with fangs
instead of Skynet there's snake net I'm
or Diedrich break into the present days
snake net to HQ and a Pentagon
assistance is mouse-like of course a
parody of resistance is futile but with
my switch snake consider weak and
inferior slippy is now a Sarah Connor
type mother figure predicting her John
Connor babies from robot snakes in a
time-travelling muscled snake-like
Arnold's rig defeats one snake by giving
him legs making him clumsy and when they
break into the snake lab one of the
snake scientists offs himself rick has
to finish inventing time travel for the
snakes and receives the tech in snake
suits from the future Rick and future
Morty sending them to stake MIT in 1985
now here you can see snake b-boys one
with kitten play hare snakes doing blow
one is a popped collar and an anarchy
pin there's a female snake wearing the
80s fashion and she joins a snake with
an 80 cell phone inside the lab there
are posters for a snake back to the
future and snake Michael Jackson's bad
and a Rubik's Cube and a few snake nerds
show up after one has a mullet and a
shirt with a rainbow banana for the
old-school Apple logo
I guess bananas are the more serpentine
shaped fruit the 80 snakes fast track
and over do time travel they seek to
prevent Lincoln's assassination in 1865
with Ford's snake theater of course
covered in serpentine imagery snake
Lincoln and snake Mary Todd sit in a
booth with snake George watching that's
portrait there and dodged a bullet from
snake John Wilkes Booth and back in the
president the butterfly effect causes
reality to have been reset as a Nazi one
a call actually fascist the dimensions
of the season premiere his snake friend
cig Hales and the walls are covered in
snake swastikas and a bust of snake
Lincoln with a Hitler mustache and a
dead mouse in a jar underneath because a
lot of thought experiments have
speculated that President Lincoln was a
bit fascist he did suspend habeas corpus
not saying it was good that he died we
just don't know how history would've
played out in snake Berlin in 1938 snake
Hitler salutes his followers all of whom
have Rattlers suggesting maybe a racial
divide might be based on Rattlers versus
plain tales
snake Hitler's mansion has wall art of a
snake with eagle wings and a framed
portrait of a German Shepherd the most
racist dog and his bathroom has busts of
a devil snake from the garden to be
with the forbidden fruits and while in
the shower sneak Hitler finds himself at
the center of many time travel without
experiments with assassins killing each
other by the dozens one of whom has an
Arnold haircut meanwhile Jerry accept
his fate and Scrolls through photos of
his family bath carrying him on their
wedding day
more tea cleaning a nice grape cherry
and an apron delivering a drink to Rick
jerry has to leave a voicemail since
Beth hasn't saved his number on her
phone and he finds a plane to hang from
even though the pilots are doing Molly
as his fingernails bleed Jerry refuses
help from a savior human snake hybrid it
holds open a baby bjorn for him to slip
into the chair he thinks it's a Rick
trick and he kicks the snake into a jet
engine bringing down the plane making
Jerry yet another member of the Smith
family responsible for mass murder on
the ground the snake melee continues one
snake on fire a cowboy stick fights a
pharaoh snake whatever and this alerts
the time cops including me me pants
kicking Michael keys character from the
rickland time season 2 episode their HQ
is in the fourth dimension with floating
thro dingers cats from that episode and
the surrounding space reflecting the
tesseract design from the movie
interstellar the two of them jump back
in time to the Stone Age times of snake
history to beat up the very first snake
to use primitive technology on the cave
walls behind them there are cave baby
the snakes hunting woolly mammoths and
blood-spatter but with a snake tail
outline so the snakes of the present day
eat their own tails reflecting how close
loop time-travel plots themselves are
innocents snakes even their own tails
Rick confiscates Morty's adventure
punch-card
coming back the last time morty filled
that card in the season 3 of indicators
episode the most credits scene
officially closes this loop with rick
and morty having to finish inventing
time travel and sewing the host um snake
costumes to give back to their past
selves and the reveal of how morty got
that black eye his grandfather
punching him closing on a literal punch
line and that christmas card there
naturally spells christmas with multiple
ices comment down below with your
favorite joke of this episode be sure to
check out this week's episode of
explained with abbot gate and jessica
chobot where we explained the inner
workings of time travel this episode
follow me on instagram and twitter at EA
vas subscribing to rock stars so
breakdowns of everything you love and
will see in the new year when we break
down the second half of this season a
Rick and Morty thank you for joining me
bye bye
[Music]